빌사남의 간다는 세계적인 도시 그리고
제가 좋아하는 마천루들이 모여 있는
뉴욕 맨하튼에 왔습니다
[음악]
어 저는 한인타운에 와 있습니다 어
한인타운은 맨해튼에서 32번 가에
위치하고 있는데 여기 역사가 그렇게
길지 않아요 그래서 제가 좀 짧게
설명드리자면
1970년도에 저희 한인분들이 여기
미국으로 이민을 많이 왔습니다
그러다가
1980년도에 여기 한식당들이 한두
개씩 생겨나기 시작했는데 그때 당시만
하더라도 여기 임대료가 그렇게 높지
않았습니다 어 1990년도에 여기가
좀 활성화되기 시작을 했습니다 근데
그때 당시에 한국 경제력 수준이 되게
높아지면서 유학을 되게 많이 왔거든요
유학이나 뭐 비즈니스를 뉴욕으로 많이
하는데 그렇게 여행 오신 한국인
분들이 이쪽을 좀 많이 이용하면서
여기 상권이 되게 활성화되기
시작했습니다
2000년도부터는 이제 한류 열풍
으면서 외국인들이 여기를 좀 많이
찾기 시작했는데 지금도 거리를
보시면은 외국인들이 좀 굉장히 많아요
그래서 제가 지금 위치한 곳은 32번
과에서 되게 유명한 마트인 h 마트
앞에 와 있습니다 그래서 제가
여기서부터 한번 좀 32번 가를 좀
보여 드릴 거고 그리고 여기 가다
보면 최근에 매각 사례가 좀 있거든요
그래서 그 매각 사례도 제가
설명드리도록 하겠습니다
[음악]
가시죠 여기가 이제 상권이 좋아지다
보니까 임대료가 굉장히 좀 많이
오르기 시작했어요 그러면서 좀 이렇게
준비를 잘하신 분들은 직접 건물을
매입하실 분들도 몇몇 분 계십니다
그래서 여기도 제가 은행을 알아보니까
매입해서 쓴다라고 하면은 대출 조건이
좋다라고 합니다 여기 32번 가도
식당 장사하시는 분이 꽤 매입을
했는데 지금이 사례 같은 경우에도
여기에서 매장을 운영하시는 분이
샀어요네 그래서 지금 보이는 저
건물입니다 그래서이 건물에 좀 개요를
말씀드리자면 돼지가 약 한 340평
정도 되고 지상 층 건물입니다 그래서
연면적이 무려 약한 3,200명 정도
되는데 3,700만 달러 그러니까
한국 돈으로 보자면 약 한 500억
정도의 어 매입을 한 사례입니다 좀
서울과 비교해서는 비싼 가격은 아닌
거 같아요 그래서 뭐 테란로 예를
들면 테이 난로도 지금 연면적당
가격이 한 4 5천만 원 정도 되는데
그거와 비교해서는 가격이 생각보다
그렇게 높지 않았습니다 밑에층 같은
경우에는 아마 이제 직접 쓰실 거
같고 그리고 위에 층은 지금 오피스로
되어 있는데 이거는 이제 주거 시설로
바꿀 예정이라고 합니다 일단은요 정도
규모가 한 500억 정도 된다라는
거네 그리고 여기가 임대료가 높다
보니까 한식당들이 여기 들어오기 좀
쉽지 않거든요 그래서 여기 인근으로
좀 매장을 얻거나 최근에 뜨고 있는
뭐 플랫 아이언 빌딩 있는 인근이나
아니면 첼시 지역에 좀 많이 오픈을
한다라고 하는데 일단은 여기 인근에서
되게 유명한 한식당이 있습니다 그래서
제가 한번 좀 현장에 가가지고 어
사장님도 좀 간단하게 제가 좀
인터뷰를 해 보도록 하겠습니다 한번
그쪽으로 이동해
[음악]
보시죠 저기 뒤에 있는 간판
보이시나요 어이 가게가 뉴욕 타임즈에
나온 미국인들이 가장 좋아하는
음식점이라고 합니다 미국인들 테
국밥은 굉장히 좀 생소할 수 있는데
제가 한번 직접 들어가서 식사도
해보고 간단하게 인터뷰도 해보도록
하겠습니다 들어가
보시죠 저는 한 20년 가까이
요리사로서 일을 했고요 졸업후에
여기저기 호텔 레스토랑 근무하다가
2017년에 창업한 것이 옥동식
돼지곰탕 전문점입니다
한국에서도 확장을 하려고 주위에서
많이 이렇게 조언도 해주시고 문인도
많았는데 저는 한국에서 확장할 계획은
없었어요 처음부터 아 처음부터 없었
그냥 매장 하나만 제대로 해서 정말
전통 있는 백년 가게를 만들어
보자라는 생각이었고 제 개인적인
생각은 한국에서 프랜차이즈 사업은 안
된다라고 생각을 해요 하면 안
된다라고 생각을 해요 너무너무 굉장히
치라고 그러면 음식의 퀄리티라 여러
가지 그 레스토랑의 퀄리티가 떨어질
수밖에 없고 손님의 선택지가 너무
많아지면 오히려 더 고를 수가 없는
상황이 돼 버려요 그럼 여러 가지
우리나라 외식 환경이 선순환이 되는게
아니라 악순환이 될 수밖 없는 거죠
그런 상황이 너무 싫었기 때문에 요리
없게 오랫동안 몸 담한 저로서는 그런
걸 좀 저 스스로 그 안에 들어가고
싶지 않았어요 그렇다고 내가 확장을
하겠다고 해외에 눈 놀린 건 아닌데
우연 찬 기회에 뉴욕이라는 곳을 한번
경험해 보고 싶어서 여행을 왔다가 제
대학 동기를 만나고 지금의 제 사업
파트너인 지금 핸드 하스피탈리티
대표님을 알게 돼서 팝업을 준비했고
4개월간 팝업을 하면서 너무너무
반응이 좋아서 어 정식 오픈 합시다
해서 이제 23년 4월에 정식
오픈하게 됐죠
너무 새로운 형태였기 때문에 기존의
한식이 아니라 지금 유혹에 있는 한식
당들 많이 있지만 대중적인 음식들
수로 생각을 해본다면 기존에 있든가
좀 다른 개념이 있기 때문에 되게
충격적이었다고 말씀들을 많이 해
주시고 실제 외국인들의 반응도 큰
거부감 없이 즐길 수 있는 음식이라는
평이 이어져서 뉴욕 타임즈 피트
웰스의 좋은 평가를 받았던 거 같아요
그렇구나 최근에 이렇게 뉴욕 진출하고
싶어하는 fb 사장님들이 되게
많더라고요 그래서 되게 좀 민감한네
질문일 수도
있는데 그거는 말씀드릴 수 없는데
기본적으로 한국의 오픈 비용이 한
세배 된다고 보시면 돼요 아 세 배
정도 생각보다 굉장히 기가 많이
들어가고 시간이 일단 많이 들어가기
때문에 그만큼 비용이 더 들어가는
거죠 허가하지 이런게 복잡하고
네네네 특별한 건 없어요 여기도 사람
되다 보니까 먹고 사는게 문제고
식문화에 있어서 차이가 있다라고
하지만 먹는 거의 차이지 어떤 행위에
대해서는 제가 볼 때네 큰 차이는
없어요이 분들한테도 맛있는 건 맛있는
거고 맛없는 건 맛없는 거예요 그냥
편안하게 맛있는 거 다 똑같이 즐길
수 있고 똑같이 표현을 해요
맛있다라고네이 댓글들이 이렇게 유튜브
올로 하는 글들 보면 한국인들이
느끼는 바가지라고 이렇게 팁
때문이에요 팀문화 때문에 팁이 뭐
이렇게 많냐데 지금은 최하가 18
거의 지금 20% 가까이 저희는
저희는 18% 거의 20% 터
시작하는데 되게 많아요 그 자체가
너무 바가지라고 느낄 수 있죠 근데
저는 그래요 다른 문 에서 왔고
여기서 와서 먹고 그게 부담스러우면
굳이 안 내도 돼요 내 내라고
강요하지도 않아요 안 내고 가면
그만이에요 하지만 본인이 그 서비스에
만족했고 그 음식을 정말 맛있게
먹었다고 한다면 본인이 낼 수
있는만큼내는 건 정말 좋은 일이라고
봐요 지금 유혹은 조금 과한 거 있다
과한건 있다네 그렇게 볼 수
있어요 한국에서 만약에 뉴욕을 진출
하고 싶다 한다고 했을 때 단독으로
하기 힘들 거예요 누군가 뉴욕에서
하는 파트너를 만난다든지 이런 가의
도움을 받지 않으면 사실은 어려운
부분이에요네
그렇구나네 저는 아이템을 국밥으로
그러니까 유혹을 진출하게 해서 국밥을
잡은게 안 척하던게 국밥이 있기
때문에 그걸로 가능성을 받기 때문에
들어온 거지 타켓팅을 해서 들어온 건
아니에요 그렇 한국에서 이제 하면서
외국인들 많이 렇 그렇죠 외국인들
반응이 너무 좋았기 때문에 테이블에서
느낄 수 없는 감성이 지고를 막는
동등한 위치에서 감 같이 산다 직접
만드신 분이라 이렇게 눈 마주치면서
이렇게 하는게 되게 신뢰도 더 주는
거고 그 그러면 혹시 플린트 적어요
왜냐면 우리가 이렇게 내려다보고
있잖아요 꼭 그런 건 아니지만 손님
입장에서는 또 그런 어떤 리스펙한
마음도 있고 그러다 보니까 더 음식에
집중할 수
있고음 지금 저한테도 문의가 많이
오고 뭐 최근 한 몇 달 동안 너무나
많이 한국의 브랜드들이 들어온다는
얘기도 많이 들었어요 준비하고 있는
것도 몇 군도 있는 거 같고 근데
이미 유혹 시장도 포화 상태고 전
세계적인 경계 불기 를 접어들어서
이거는 뉴욕이라고 제외 순 없거든요
물론 뉴욕이 다른 데보다 낫다고
하지만 실제 경험을 해 보면 그렇지도
않아요 뉴욕 같은 경우에 런치 시장이
많이 죽었고 예전에 비해서 런치를
거의 안 사 먹어요 안 사 먹어요
20불 넘어가는 그런 식사를 하려고
본인이 20불을 내고 먹지 않아요
정말 싸게 먹거나 뭐 샐러드 같은 거
먹거나 길거리 음식을 먹거나 10불
원자리 정도 되는 것들을 사 먹지 그
왜냐면 여기도지 불경기가 기사에 뭐
목 동식이 어떤 애 뭐 다른 한신
레스토랑들이 엄청 인기다 그거는 그냥
그 보여주는 것뿐이 그 이면을 들려다
보면 여기도 되게 힘들어요 여기도
마찬가지 한국도 지금 구인 난이라고
하는데 미국도 마찬가지예요 사람
구하기 힘들어 너무 힘들어요 그런
거를 다 고려하고 결정하셔야 만 되고
어 막 성공했다 그래서 그게 그게
보이는게 다가 아닌데 그것만 보고
도전하시는 분들이 블라 방처럼 다
진짜 너무 많아요 절대 안 돼요 그런
얘기만 듣고 왔다가 실패한 경우가
너무 많이 왔어 진짜 준비 기간도
글고 비용도 많이 들어가고 진짜
파트너도 좀 필요하고 적의 문제도
많이 있고 그렇죠 그리고 이제 사람
구하기도 어렵고 쉽지 않네요 꾼이
없겠어요 한국에 그런 외식 하시는
분은 부동산 브로커 잘 못 만나가지고
공사도 못 하고 삽도 못 두고
렌트비만 1년 동안 내다가 그냥
포기하고 가는 사람도 있어요 아
[음악]
그래요네 그래서 지금 옥동식 대표님과
인터뷰를 좀 마쳤는데 저는 그냥
인터넷 기사로만 봤을 때는 정말
어떻게 보면 돈을 많이
버시나요네 진짜 1도 되게 심하고
그고 좋 옥동식 대표님 말씀처럼 짜
20달러 미만으로 식사를 많이
해결한다고 합니다 그래서 그만큼 되게
경기 상황이 좀 좋지 않은 거 같아요
그리고 가장 네트에서 임대가 잘되는
곳이 제일 임대료가 낮은 곳이었습니다
그거와 같이 사람들이 되게 가성비를
많이 찾기 시작한 거 같아요 만약에
이제 뉴욕에 진출하고 싶어하시는
fmb 사장님이 계시다고 하면은 정말
철저한 계획으로 치밀하게 오랜 기간을
가지고 고려를 해보셔야 될 것
같습니다 그리고 여러분들 뉴욕에 왔을
때 관광 명소가 타임스퀘어 엠파이어
스테이트 뭐 록펠러 센터 등이 있지만
최근에 mg 세대들이 많이 찾는 곳이
있습니다 바로 첼시 제가 이번에
첼시로 가서 왜 mg 세대들이 많이
오고 여기가 각광을 왜 봤는지 확인해
보도록 하겠습니다 빌딩은 역시 빌사남
[음악]
Me Now we
about
we
we sometimes
me little
[음악]